hello into account is yo planes signs
Sun Tzu chespin from Brazil okay the
other six d3 line one of the current
main tries for y2 I'm avoid the Marshall
which I will never play anyway but still
rather popular okay he cannot and all
that that had on played the marshal so
yeah I've had this on the board quite
often and still have not really still
didn't have a close look yet at this at
this opening line
I just hope I'm getting away with
playing normal-looking moves maybe I'm
not good see okay so try to open the SOB
here we go back for possible night to be
six
can always tough those positions many
pieces on the board and it's kind of
yeah it's it's difficult it's very
difficult to to to get gets a grip on
what's what's going on okay so what you
do here I can trade it like that it's
really annoying okay he allows me to do
that okay I'm happy about this 13c for
Naga G of course for prevent
it's not so easy actually I mean I'm
quite sure what it doesn't prevent it
okay maybe he didn't have a way to
prevent it but this just wind stuff now
okay um pawn takes rook chicks politics
up probably rook takes this e for
winning even most more material now then
you can actually move the rook but I can
take and play you for so you cannot take
now with the rook so this is really
getting annoying for him so what now
night to be six night to f6 those come
to mind your voice is also move yeah
this is probably might be six would be
am sorry night mc4 would have been cool
to get in to get in and this is also
looking pretty strong keeping all those
pants there in the middle okay so yeah
Bo the rook is not really a big deal if
i can if i give this up but there's no
need i think i can i can sacrifice on c6
probably let's do it this will lead to a
pawn and ponder bigpond mass in the
center
yeah once to Bishop takes Queen h6 stuff
definitely don't want that Bishop t6 is
coming
and even f4 is a move but which what is
the easiest here maybe we should be five
just just finish on c3 here
ok maybe we should be five check
oopsie one what's the bot city of their
bishop dunne 26 maybe Wow
hmm I'm to do this he wants to take a
father take on d3 and clean take the
screen g6 check
you
hmm that's bad I want to join ah shoot
he swindled himself out of this I cannot
believe it I can't believe it I cannot
believe it ah oh my god chapter was
probably like minus a million position
fantastic really fantastic stuff
time morning absolutely amazing let us
manage to screw up positions that good
I want to gamble here and this is what i
get this is what i get black resign oh
my god there was everything is like
amazing what kind of game was that yeah
cause everything winds now but I managed
to screw it up it's amazing yeah it's
amazing how you can do it this this is
just totally idiotic it just totally
idiotic I can take here and it's just
open I'm protecting of this damn rook I
was seeing this idea right but are
attacking the rook so he has to move the
rook first and then he goes wherever it
really doesn't matter and I do whatever
and he resides no yeah it's kind of
pointless to analyze this because he
just blundered plundered the whole game
here and it's it's very straightforward
actually I just have to just have to win
this position which is you're not
particularly difficult if you are like
how many points it's two pawns and the
whole position of course check yeah I
simply didn't see that d3 Hanks I mean
the position is still better for black
but currently I was so unnerved that
this is [ __ ] sorry this game was
still kind of this is still winning from
black actually because he cannot defend
here no it cannot defend this bloody
bishop I'm threatening here like I take
a clay and place it too and it's
it's amazing chat kind of how many
adopting moves did I need to play to
make them to lose the game even here
it's still completely ok now you can do
whatever and then I play this vicious
it's really like cool it's the only move
that allows this for being really really
good yeah i mean if i want to avoid the
draw so i can and i'll play this or
whatever yeah and then continue he has
no advantage here anyway and there's 30
seconds down 20 seconds now a
premiership these surveillances it's an
art form it's really like setting this
up it's amazing ok ah thanks for
watching